[Music]
almost two years ago i uploaded a video
titled
who are the hunters and like everything
i've produced up until now
it was just something that interested me
very little was discussed about them in
the game
so after researching everything that i
could find on them i realized that i
wasn't alone with these questions
there were so many active theories on
them but most didn't line up with my
understanding of the story at that point
so i decided to pull together some of
the larger theories out there including
a few of my own
and talk about the likelihood of each of
them i had no idea that others would
find this as interesting as i did
it was only my second lore video and
this one was more speculation than law
itself
a little under a year later i released
an update to this video
talking to some of the feedback
considering the first video but also a
number of new theories that had come up
since the release of the division 2.
and here we are today another 12 months
on this video is more of a small
update to the series of videos that have
been running for the last two years
unfortunately the hunters have taken an
odd turn in the story since they were
first released in the survival expansion
of the original game
the hunters seem to have become more of
a puzzle element to the game than part
of the story
so there isn't actually a huge amount
more that we have to work with
however thanks to one keynote member on
discord there may be a little something
more that we have to go on
i receive hundreds of theories and
images every month from people
interested in finding out more about the
division story
most of them i've seen or talked about
before but every now and then
something catches me by surprise a
discord user that goes by the name of
monarch sent me some information he'd
been compiling regarding the new hunters
that we were finding after the release
of warlords of new york
i'll be the first to admit i wasn't
hugely excited at first but then he sent
me through this image
this is a picture of warlords of new
york hunter angel
while this alone may not seem very
significant over time monarch sent me
more images like this
from other hunters he was able to take
down time and time again
the same tattoo so what does this mean
it could mean absolutely nothing these
could just be duplicated models
with zero significance around the tattoo
but the devs and ubisoft games love
leaving little tidbits and clues around
that could lead to a greater story so we
investigated further
fortunately monarch used to be part of a
us milsim role play group
and had some knowledge in this area but
also has a contact with ties to the army
on top of this i ran this past a number
of other people with experience in the
area
including twitter user james hurt their
conclusions were all the same
a lot of military tattoos represent the
brotherhood they had in their time of
service
or are from a certain battle that he or
she lost friends in
or it could be something more personal
to the individual
but there appears to be military ranks
on either side and there was no
variation
between each hunter they confirmed these
as u.s army ranks
or more specifically united states army
first sergeant
private and private first class
i went back through my footage of
division 1 hunters and the first hunters
seen in the division 2
some of which is playing on screen right
now but in both cases
their arms seem to be covered down to
the forearm so i couldn't confirm that
they too have the same tattoos
but i have since found a number of
images to the earlier division 2 hunters
who do have these
a first class sergeant serves as a
senior enlisted advisor to the commander
of a medium to large unit of marines
such as a platoon or company as the
senior enlisted advisor
first sergeants hold the responsibility
of being the main bridge between
enlisted marines
and their company commander they may be
united states special operations command
or more specifically either delta force
seals special operations group
or green berets but they also could be a
black ops unit
special operations group or green braise
can operate alone due to the nature of
their missions
if the hunters are in fact from these
units within the military this could
explain the reason behind the guerrilla
warfare tactics
and how they combat other units and why
they dress in plain clothes
could even coincide to other links
within the tom clancy universe like the
ghosts
or rainbow six private military
contractors are often made up of people
with previous military experience so
it's no surprise to see that a number of
black tusks are also sporting tattoos
however what is surprising is the number
of black tusks who have exactly the same
tattoo as the hunters
all the way down to the ranks and the
image in the centre
riflemen bernadieres engineers the
bosses in the invaded capitol hill and
viewpoint museum missions
even brenner
so what does this all mean well it tells
us a couple of things
the hunters originated from the us or at
the very least come from a u.s military
background
yes you could loosely theorise that the
russians had them get these tattoos to
provide them some sort of undercover
illusion that they are americans
but the earlier hunters didn't even show
them and to have the exact same tattoos
as the black tusk
seems unlikely so i'm going to discredit
the hunters are russian special forces
theory for now it also seems to show
that they have some sort of ties to the
black tusk
at the very least they come from the
same u.s military unit
but they could in fact be a part of the
black tusk the black tusk we come across
in the division are from a more
specialized branch of the overall
company called the btsu
or black tusk special unit maybe the
hunters are a special unit within the
special unit
the black tusk super special unit if you
like
or what if they attempted to gain
employment through the black tusk with
the rest of their squad
but were deemed too aggressive or
generally unsuitable for the general
cohesion of one of their specialist
units
and they were instead brought on as a
hired gun to take out former and current
division agents
this actually may explain their
obsession with collecting agent watches
these are essentially their paycheck
however this doesn't exactly write off
the third wave or contingency theory
either
the hunters are obviously highly trained
forces particularly in guerilla warfare
tactics
they use the same tech as the division
if not slightly better
and as far as the tattoo goes maybe they
just have a similar history to the black
tusk
but took a different direction after the
time in the military
i realize this has probably only raised
even more questions
but this has given us a little more to
work with given the direction that the
hunters have taken since the division
one there really hasn't been too much to
work with
let's face it when we think about the
hunter's involvement in the story up
until this point
basically they've become nothing more
than a puzzle to solve in order to
acquire a new mask
and i do wonder if we had been given
their full story by now
would they have long since faded into
oblivion
but at this point i want to hand this
over to you what do you think this
tattoo means
is there anything else you can share on
the hunters that could lead to further
theories on their origins and objectives
personally i'm wanting to dig a little
deeper into someone that we saved early
on in dc
vikram malik i think there is a lot more
to the story
and i've seen enough to think that he
could have some sort of involvement with
the hunters
but time will tell otherwise i must
thank monarch for his research on this
and all the information he provided
and also james hurt for his feedback
thanks again for watching and i'll catch
you in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
uh